the jurogan experience jacques valet
uh you have been studying this most of
your life
too long too long we discussed it
last night at dinner that um your
interest in this came from
an experience that you actually had as a
child you actually saw a ufo
as a as a teenager with two other
witnesses
uh one of the witnesses was half a mile
away with binoculars so
i'm pretty sure that that that object
was real
and it was a classic disc middle of the
afternoon clear sky
absolutely clear at the time i became
convinced that
it might be a prototype of something
that would be
coming out later and you know we're here
many years later and we still don't have
anything like that it was just hovering
and
it was fair and you've been studying
this for so long and this is uh
something you guys talked about in the
film that you were actually the
character that the french
ufo researcher in close encounters of
the first kind or the third kind rather
was modeled after
the stephen spielberg film spielberg was
intrigued with the idea of a
of a character that was not quite as
weird
as you know the et's but was a lot
weirder than
you know the the people on the ground in
the us trying to
make sense of this in the military and
so on so he needed this intermediate
character and
he thought you know frenchman was was
the right
thing to do and so did you talk to him
about the film
did you talk to him about when when he
was putting it together and yeah
i uh journalists put us together
when about halfway through the you know
the final
final shooting of the film and there
were there were gaps in the movie at
that point and
we so we had lunch twice together
and uh it was was a lot of fun he was
at the time he was looking for a
transition between the time when
they they know the you know the big
thing is coming
the mothership is coming and they don't
know where
and the mothership is sending signals
but they can't decipher
the signals and i he said you know he
had spent the morning at
the jet propulsion laboratory and he
said he couldn't
make any sense of all the mathematics
they had
and i said well maybe you could have you
know two
screens that give you an angle and and
the angle
tells you where the thing is and he said
now that's too complicated you know and
takes too long right it has got to be
just a few minutes in the film
and then i i thought of a photograph
that was on the desk of dr heineck
you know dr j j heineck who was the air
force consultant on ufos at the time and
i was
working with him building databases and
so on
and on that photograph there were three
guys
you know really well-dressed on ladders
around a huge um sphere of the earth
in the lobby of some building somewhere
with pieces of string
that they were they were putting the
string over the earth
and i i i told dr heineck i said alan
you know
what's the story behind this and and he
said well
the when the first sputnik was launched
you know october 57
nobody had a computer program to compute
an orbit
but they knew where the sputnik had been
seen nobody expected
the russians to come up with this and
they needed to know where it was going
next so they the
new york times called the director of
harvard
observatory saying um can you give us a
comment on the russian satellite and the
guy said
hey it's 3 o'clock in the morning you
know what russian satellite
and so they got dressed in a hurry and
they
they were trying to compute the orbit by
putting
a string around around the model of the
earth in the lobby of the
of harvard and i thought it was so funny
and and spielberg said
that's it you know that's it the the
general says
come on uh you know you know the the
geographer
who is uh the interpreter of the french
of a french guy
uh says well it looks like it's
somewhere in wyoming you know but
where in wyoming you know where should
we go and
the the general says you mean we've got
10 billion dollars worth of radar and
you know
cameras and everything else nobody's got
a map of wyoming
and they break into the lobby of the
building next door and they come back
with this globe
and you know they've got the globe and
they they look at
it look at it and get their coordinates
and
because they it turns out the geographer
tells them
you know those signals they look like a
longitude in the latitude so
they they they cris you know they they
get the point where it's going to be
and that's that was a piece that was
missing
in in the movie so i was really proud of
that you know it was
it was really fun well also it's the one
funny part in the movie
yeah it's a great movie and it's uh it
is probably the movie that got me most
excited about ufos when i was a kid
and i remember thinking if ufos were
coming here from another planet one
thing that i remember thinking is why
would they even bother talking to the
government like
what do they care who the government is
like if if i was
looking at an ant colony i'm not going
to ask the ant colony which one's the
the elected official that's in charge of
all the other ants
you don't give a [ __ ] you're just like
trying to study the ants and i felt like
if something was coming here from
another planet that was so sophisticated
it could
either travel from another dimension or
travel from another galaxy
why would it care like who the president
is or who the generals are
you know not only that but the witnesses
don't talk to the government either
you know by now the witnesses are tired
of being ridiculed
by scientists and you know by
and told that those things don't exist
so they don't
they don't talk so they'll talk to you
know
people like you people like me
because i trust you know they they trust
me
and in silicon valley you know you
wouldn't believe the number of
people who come to me you know including
ceos of
companies that i've worked with who tell
me about
sightings that people in their family
have had or sightings
they had including you know sightings in
vietnam for example and so on
when they were in the military that have
never been reported
and and the government isn't getting
that
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience